let me ask you a controversial question
yes should comics be doing like 10
specials or is it time to hang it up
is it time what's going on i don't want
to do a special unless i have to talk
about something
right right do you know what i'm saying
like yeah i mean there's so many comics
have been around forever since we're two
yeah is it time for any of them to leave
and this is one of my
this is one of the things i say and i
want the tim do i want to do the tim
dillon show
answer or do is it the real answer it's
the real answer the real answer is
keep on doing so the wheels fall off it
makes you happy the tim dillon show
answers
a lot of guys gotta go a lot of guys
gotta go
i love you but you gotta go you gotta go
and i respect you
and you've done it but what are we still
doing
at a certain point right at a certain
point
you've done it like how much can you do
it
like it's you know yeah what do you see
yeah i mean i get it if it makes you
happy do whatever makes you happy what
if we
don't do what makes me happy and what
makes me
happy is you not doing this anymore they
have to go yes
or yes yeah they gotta go i love you i
think
yeah yes or yes we should do a yearly
purge of them
yeah we just sit down it has to happen
and we just instead of like the time
what is going to happen to comedy clubs
in this in in this
i think comedy clubs are good because i
think that's i think comedy clubs are
going to be good
they'll be good i think they can hang on
because it's just a hard yeah economic
thing a lot of them will hang on yeah
for whatever reason i think a lot of
them will but i think they're good and i
think that will be one of the first
experiences that people go back out in
public to do
yeah it's kind of safe you're not making
out with strangers in a dance floor
right you are already somewhat distance
guys
you're with your friends you're laughing
and you're kind of like somebody's
regaling the times and you want to
relate to i think right i think they'll
thrive yeah but um
100 the comedy club is where we'll be
working on our bits and then have these
kind of intimate experiences
but when it comes to creating a show
yeah
the reality is if i'm doing the garden
yeah and i'm making fun of someone in
the front row
nobody else in the garden can see that
person in the front right so i have to
change
my show to accommodate
that venue the venue right experience
you can't
even doing the the monologue what we're
doing it's like i have to constantly
change what i'm doing like right early
in my career i was just doing material i
put out two special
materials right okay i got really good
at that and i'm not trying to pat myself
in the background i was really good at
it
right what am i not really good at how
can i get better
let's get better yeah okay i see these
guys doing monologues all the time never
once have i thought they're funny
right and i'm just like how has nobody
tried to do this funny yet right
they suck right okay maybe i could i'm
terrified of looking like an idiot
right terrified good i should go do that
thing i'm terrified of
we start doing it and then why don't
people do more [ __ ] that scares them
why do you think i don't know i mean i
i i would say that you it's painful
yeah but you will do it why will you do
it i mean i'm a little crazy you're a
little crazy
but you also don't have shame i want i
don't have shame you won't [ __ ]
fail
no it's just this hoodie that i that
everyone makes fun of me for
because i did a sketch with it on right
but when i put this hoodie on
i become a different person people don't
understand i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
about politics anymore
when i put this hoodie on i don't care
about [ __ ] oh do you read a book what
book you read
you want to [ __ ] yo what do you
think's gonna happen no no yeah when i
put this hoodie on i realize
that i am beautiful you are gorgeous and
that yeah cause the black man came up to
me and he said you look fresh as [ __ ]
when i had this on yeah and no one had
ever been complimentary to me like that
before
yeah and i've discovered that i can be a
new person which is to one garment of
clothing
and i could maybe start smoking weed
again and doing pills and drinking that
coffee
that person doesn't have a drug problem
the person in this is responsible
he can no but i i you know mike lawrence
said some really good ones somebody said
i'm afraid to do this show and mike
lawrence goes are you too good to fail
i've never felt like i was too good to
fail yeah i think that's part of why i
do [ __ ]
i don't feel like i'm too good to fail
yeah i don't feel like i'm too if i put
out a
[ __ ] video and it gets a few thousand
views that's okay
a lot of comics don't want to start
pursuing [ __ ] online because they're
like what am i gonna have to build this
[ __ ]
social media network yeah you do in the
beginning yeah you do you have to do it
yeah and keep
doing it yeah and it is what it is in
the beginning we i had no followers i
had nothing
you know but i i don't feel like too
good to i feel like i gotta as long as
i'm playing
i'm okay if i'm on the field i'm okay if
i'm
on the bench pointing at people on the
field going [ __ ] them
loser that's where i get depressed
yeah i gotta play yeah and if that's the
way that i i feel good about myself
decent about myself not tremendous but
there's a guy i grew up with siddiqui
thomas right yes jamaican dude
yeah hilarious he would hit on every
girl
right he would he would his rate of like
closing was probably like
two out of ten or three out of ten right
which is good okay
it's good yeah i didn't think he was a
loser when he failed
right i thought he was the bravest
[ __ ] i've ever seen
because when i was young i was terrified
right of not only getting rejected but
my friends seeing me get rejected right
and then then i thought in my
mind i was like i'm gonna lose some sort
of social currency to my friends
they think i'm cool the bravest thing
anyone can do right now literally to me
yeah is talk to a woman to
sit down and speak to a woman and listen
to them and take their opinion
seriously is to me braver
than jumping out of a plane without a
parachute in my life
like for me to have to do that yeah is
huge so that's a big
no no upside for you very little upside
well winning company gave us that table
in the back which we paid her for
she keeps acting like it's charity i'm
like we just gave you money
yeah it sounds enough yeah but i love
her i love winnie
because whitney is a power you know
she's a real [ __ ]
she's a great comic and she's a great
comic great unstoppable force
unstoppable force
she will get it done she'll get it she's
not afraid as well she thinks she's
afraid
right but that is what pushes her does
that make sense how do you
when you see people that
do you believe that hard work is genetic
george carlin said maybe it is genetic
there's something very interesting about
that yeah i know people who i look at
what is it um nature versus nurture i
think it's
it's nurture but i think you have to see
hard work at a very young age
to get it to and then that's yeah i saw
my mom getting up every day yeah
coaching a swim team getting up at 5am
doing everything uh i
i get it i also saw my dad who i loved
like
you know was a really great musician but
never took it to the level he could have
yeah i so i
had both of those experiences right why
were you afraid of repeating what your
dad
oh yeah i was afraid of having a studio
in my house in the suburbs yeah
uh where like my dad oh no
my dad had a studio or he would just sit
in a room in his house in the suburbs
but no one cared he was just playing his
guitar okay
that's way different totally different i
have one father yeah and
um he but no i was afraid of and my dad
was a really talented guy and i was
talented because i knew that because
other people would tell me he wouldn't
like other people would say you're dead
at this massive band on long island the
70s was really big
did you know about that i'm like kinda
and my dad didn't really keep a lot of
that stuff around right there was no
like photos of it
so i was like oh okay catholic thing
like no just didn't i think
he didn't want to remind himself that he
was on this track that never paniced
out yeah it's hard yeah it's tough right
and i get it he had a kid either well
you gotta
you know got a sales job or whatever but
i when i got into this i was 25 years
old and i'm like
this is the last thing that i have the
shot to be good at
there's not a lot of things you can do
at 25 right i mean
there's some certainly but a lot this is
the other thing about life that people
don't really want to
talk about which is like you know at a
certain point you gotta you gotta
make uh uh a decision and stick with it
you don't you can't reinvent yourself
every three years what point you think i
don't know i don't think it's 25
no i don't think it'll be later i think
i don't think it's a specific age okay
i think that it's a it's a it's a moment
and i don't think i don't think you can
uh reinvent everything you want like i
know people that have wanted to be ten
things yeah and i'm like well this is a
problem yeah every three years you want
to be another thing
and you know what i notice about those
people the each one of those things
has one thing in common right and
they're just
lily padding to the next thing because
that one isn't working and it's usually
validation i look at yes it's like i
want people to like me okay i'm going to
do
i'm going to be an actress it doesn't
work i'm going to be a pilates coach
that's on youtube uh it's not really i
look at people that are really funny and
i say to myself
i look at people that are really funny
and haven't made a
haven't made much of their careers and i
and i and i and i think a lot of that is
because
they they don't get bored easily i get
very bored
who is that i look at comics that are
very funny that haven't
built a fan base that's a lot of people
right
is it no that's the thing like there's
really there's i don't want to be
insulting but there's there are guys
that we know that should be bigger
i can and i would be bigger it is yes
and i think it's but they have drug
issues
usually people that that are no yeah i
don't know i don't know
what they do there's different levels of
funny right like if we're just being
honest let's be honest
there is a lot of young comics you're
going to listen to this they should and
they should [ __ ] pay extra close
attention
because they're not the elite level of
funny yet yes and you and i were
in young comics i mean bill burns no i'm
just kidding i just i'm just
i'm kidding but uh like you and i were
both
at the at the point where we're not
funny right and then we start to get to
the point where we're funny right
but we're not elite funny yet yes and
then we get to the point where
you want to get to elite funny right and
people are elite funny it's so hard to
get to
now it's hard to get to but they are
making a living even if they're
[ __ ] drug addicts they're making a
living yeah if they're drug addicts
they're not as
famous as they should be but they're
still living
they're living that's how yeah few
people are elite
right that's a great point there's so
this this is such a small group of
people
it gets whittled down it constantly gets
whittled down there's a hand
full of people there's really a handful
of us like when you think about so it's
like
there's a lot of people in the middle
and they're like why don't i have a
career it's like well that's not how it
works
yeah this [ __ ] is too fun for everybody
to do it yeah so if you want to have
the career career you have to be elite
right
don't you think there's a value in the
fact that people like you
and i think people like me get bored
with shittiestly we get bored and we go
i want to do cool [ __ ] and new [ __ ] i
can tell you exactly why i love stand up
yeah
because it is the basketball hoop
changing height every single time you go
on the court
right so you practice your free throws
on a tempo yeah right are you like i got
that down
right and then you go up at hilarity's
and clearly there's a way that we can
use a white sport
yes just for my yes is the tennis
i got it right okay okay ready yes here
we go
i'm ready tennis yes every time you go
onto the court
you have a different size racket wow yes
now you're with me
yes so now you're like i perfected it
with that one racket
but i met hilarity's and it's this tiny
little racquet and now when i try to
serve it doesn't do the whole so i gotta
figure out
i gotta figure out how to be so good at
this no matter what size racket i have
yeah
it's i'm gonna be successful and that's
gonna take you [ __ ] decades
so people like you and i that can get
bored of [ __ ] that we can get good at
quickly right
we're going to go okay okay i'm moving i
know some of these young guys who say
things like i just want a good quality
of life
kill yourself right yeah yeah yeah i
love that
yeah why are we yeah
why would you tell me that i want to
conquer the world
right right but it's true if you're
using those words and you're in your 20s
you're you're in trouble i mean like
you're in [ __ ] trouble i tell people
you will go no further than your dream
right with this business right right
right no further so if you just want to
make a living
that is if you're lucky right you'll get
there if you're lucky
right if you say i want to sell out
arenas
you might get to theaters yeah and
that's pretty [ __ ] that's pretty cool
right yeah but you gotta go like dreams
cost nothing
yeah as well just [ __ ] dreams yeah i
want to make a living to me you quit
already
right you quit i said that i wanted to
get killed by the cia but i may settle
for
i may settle for half a million youtube
subscribers
hey yo um